when interview someone to work at the
companies would be to ask them tell me
about the problems that they worked on
and how they sold them and if someone
was really the person who solved it
they'll be able to answer multiple
levels they'll be able to go down to the
brass tacks and if they would they'll
get stuck and then you can say oh this
person was not really the person who
solved it because anyone who struggled
hard with a problem never forgets it if
you're creating company or if you're
joining a company the most important
thing is to make sure it is to attract
great people so either of you would join
a group that's amazing that you really
respect or if you've building a company
you've got to gather great people I mean
all the company is is a group of people
that have gathered together to create a
product or service and so depending upon
how talented and hardworking that group
is and the greeter which they are
focused cohesively in a good direction
that will determine the success of the
company
so do everything you can to to gather
great people if you're creating a
company you just watch two amazing clip
some Elon Musk take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how to apply them to your business and
your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]